CHRISTOPHER CROSBIE:
Hey, everyone.
I'm excited to be here to
discuss how you can speed up
your software development with
better insights and deeper
diagnostics with new
capabilities that
have been jointly developed from
the BigQuery and Cloud Logging
teams.
I'm Christopher Crosbie.
I'm a product manager
focused on advanced analytics
here at Google Cloud.
Later I'll be joined by Charles
from the Cloud Logging team.
So a fundamental
requirement for enterprises
wanting to transform
themselves digitally
is a need to store,
manage, and analyze
large quantities of operational
data from a variety of sources.
Logs are a critical data
source for troubleshooting
machine learning, data
analytics, and security.
So while Cloud Logging
today can already
handle massive amounts of data,
capturing petabytes with ease,
many developers still struggle
to analyze this log data,
and they're unable to find
those symptoms in the log that
lead to deeper diagnostics.
And despite the large
volumes of data,
often they still find it hard
to move from a retrospective log
analysis to predictive
insights and prevent issues
before they happen.
So to help you achieve this next
level of software development
with better insight
and deeper diagnostics,
Charles and I are
thrilled to announce
Log Analytics, a new
comprehensive, easy to use,
cost effective,
and performant tool
within Cloud Logging that
has the performance and power
of BigQuery behind it.
This capability should
help you use your logging
data for both
better diagnostics,
as well as getting more
insight into your business.
Now with the companies
I've worked with,
I've seen several teams
that rely on logging data.
Yet the majority
of the users really
struggle to analyze that high
volume of messy log data.
And that leaves
organizations with a lot
of unrealized potential.
So the new Log Analytics
feature is directly
targeted at those teams who are
wrestling to extract insight
that they need from that hard
to analyze logging information.
This is targeted at DevOps
teams who want to improve system
reliability, and they might be
struggling with analyzing logs
at large scale and want a
centralized logging repository.
Or IT teams that need insight
into how to better manage
their fleet, and
they're struggling
to analyze signals across
multiple clouds or even data
centers and look at the
trends over historical amounts
of time.
Security teams that
want to identify
attacks, and they want to start
taking advantage of the latest
and greatest machine
learning and advanced
analysis techniques to
detect those threats.
Or business users that want to
make better decisions but today
they struggle to
get logs integrated
with their visualization
and analytic tools,
and they struggle to combine
their logs data and business
data.
Now when I go and
talk to these teams,
it becomes pretty obvious what
the source of their struggle
is.
What makes log
analytics hard today
is the complexity
of the data systems
that organizations need to run.
So most of you watching,
you're probably
familiar with a similar
convoluted architecture
at your own company.
Where possibly application logs,
they go into an elastic index,
and then that's where your
application performance
monitoring or Kibana
dashboards are.
But then you have
lower level operating
system network logs that flow
into a proprietary security
vendor's database.
Then of course,
there's other machine
generated logs, like maybe
from sensors or IoT data.
And they get stored
in a format that's
optimized for time
series analysis, which
is then downsampled
into a data warehouse.
And so there is a lot of
overhead with all of this,
and you definitely
pay an additional tax
for extracting and copying
all that data around.
So when I chat with the
end users of these systems,
they tell me that today's
common architecture patterns,
it generates five
critical issues
that make this log
analytics so hard.
First is the latency issues.
There's just a lot
of additional hops,
and that means data takes
longer to get to different end
systems.
Two, if no clear
source of truth.
Data transformation might
happen in multiple places.
That makes it a
challenge to understand
what's happened to the data.
Three, moving to
machine learning
requires a lot of
additional hoops.
It is not trivial to just take
a TensorFlow model or a notebook
and put that on top of
these various systems.
Four, the reliance on
multiple interfaces
where the same users need
to learn different systems
just has a whole mess of
different applications and tabs
that users have to manually
reconcile themselves.
And even with all
this user pain,
the IT teams still
have to manage
a lot of high cost
and management
complexities of running
all these different vendor
databases and applications.
When I ask customers
what they want,
it essentially
boils down to having
a separation between the
log aggregation and the log
applications.
More of our tech savvy
customers have already
started to adopt BigQuery
as their centralized log
aggregation store for data
collection, normalization,
and storage management tasks
like auditing and compliance.
Now here at Google, it
does seem intuitive to us
that customers are
choosing BigQuery
as their next generation
logging analysis platform.
Dremel, which is
the query engine
that BigQuery is based
on, that was originally
designed and built for logs.
And it's being used
for over a decade
for analyzing logs and creating
sophisticated machine learning
on those logs for some of
Google's biggest applications--
Search, YouTube, Gmail.
And so if I start
to compare BigQuery
against typical
logging platforms
that customers are using today
there's some clear advantages
that I'm seeing.
First is just the management.
Today's logging platforms
need more automation
just due to the applications
shifting into ephemeral servers
and microservice architectures.
It's just becoming way
too hard to keep up
with all the various
IT management
tasks that are required for
running the various logging
backends.
BigQuery, fully
managed, serverless.
Two, customers need
data lake scalability.
Logs are coming
from all over now.
On prem, multiple clouds,
Kubernetes, real world IoT
systems.
What used to really
be a telco scale
for a lot of these
security vendors
that relied on logs
data is pretty standard
for your average enterprise now.
And when it comes to
security analysis,
you need these logs in
a centralized place.
Threats are not system specific.
A hacker got into GCP?
Guess what, they probably
got into AWS, too.
And you want to review and
track that in one location.
It's equally
important to also have
a full history of the logs.
That's becoming more important.
If you look at something like
the recent SolarWinds attack,
that went back over 9 months.
It doesn't work
anymore to just have
30 or 60 days worth of logs
in your security database.
You need something that can
cost effectively, independently
scale the storage and
analysis like BigQuery can.
And speaking of security,
the security posture
that many of these legacy
or on prem log systems
had relied on security
controls like maybe the network
as a primary layer
of protection.
But now in our
cross cloud world,
things like network
perimeters are vanishing.
And you mix that with tougher
regulations like GDPR,
you really need a
backend now that
can help you achieve a
security posture that
makes it easy to align
for our digitalized world
and that you can trust with
your logging information.
Another big one that I'm
really hearing from customers
is a need for advanced
analytics and custom ML.
Customers are finding that these
pre-canned outlier dashboards
that their logs applications are
coming with just don't cut it
for the systems today.
I was working with
one enterprise who
moved over their existing
[INAUDIBLE] to GKE
and almost instantly got
30,000 erroneous alerts.
So customers have
told me that they
want to do their own analysis,
develop their own algorithms
that are designed for their
architecture, their business.
BigQuery is already being used
by some of the largest security
vendors out there to develop
XDR platforms as an alternative
to reactive approaches
of the [INAUDIBLE]..
And they're doing that
with GCP AI capabilities
like BQML and Vertex.
Finally, there's just
a lot of new use cases
that customers want to use,
that customers are realizing.
Customers, they understand
now that there's
a lot of business value in
joining all of this logging
data to their business
data, and then they
want to share it with others.
I'm working with an
e-commerce company who's
analyzing weblog data alongside
their clickstream data
to better understand how users
interact with their site,
and then they can offer them
better product recommendations.
And that's already led to
increased sales for them.
So having logs that can be
easily analyzed and joined
the rest of your warehouse,
that just opens up
a whole new set of use cases
like predicting customer
behavior, optimizing
online marketing campaigns,
and maybe even
understanding how employees
engage with different software
solutions in your organization.
So to unlock these use
cases and help customers
better understand the logs data
that they bring to BigQuery,
we're enhancing support
for log analytics
with investments in
three core areas.
Semi-structured
data, search indexes,
and time series analysis.
These new features
and functions are
going to let you
explore and analyze
the wealth of logging
data that you have
alongside your business data.
So with native JSON, there's
going to be a new data type
specific to JSON.
And it's going to
on a load shred
that JSON document that
can be unstructured,
constantly changing, into
a columnar store format
so you can get the same
performance and cost
effectiveness that
you've come to expect
from any other structured
data in BigQuery.
Along with that, you're going to
find additional JSON functions,
like a dot subscript notation
to make it a lot easier to work
with these JSON data sets.
Second, the search
indexes are going
to provide text indexes that
provide users the ability
to run what I call needle
in the haystack type
queries on the log data.
This is when you want to
pinpoint a very specific data
element.
So let's say I
want to find Chris
Crosbie in a petabyte
of logging data
so I can delete him
for GDPR reasons.
This search index
is going to let
you do that, or find
specific IP addresses
or other specific data elements.
Finally, coming soon
there's going to be also
TimeSeries joins and data types.
So we're going to support
joining table by arbitrary time
windows, where we
sample that data,
and you'll also be able to
store time periods, as opposed
to just a point in time.
So here at GCP we're putting
our money where our mouth is
and we're standing
behind these features
in our own logs applications.
We are using these features as
a base for our log analytics
application from Cloud
Logging, and so now I'm
going to hand you
over to Charles
to tell you more about that.
CHARLES BAER: Thanks Chris.
My name is Charles Baer.
I'm a product manager
in Cloud Logging,
and Chris and I have been
partnering on Log Analytics.
Log Analytics combines the
purpose built logging platform
provided by Cloud Logging
with BigQuery's powerful data
analytics platform.
And we build log analytics
and Cloud Logging
for three reasons.
First, ad hoc log analysis.
To empower users to answer
sophisticated questions
where ad hoc grouping can
deliver useful insights.
For log aggregation-- to
answer the types of questions
that require log aggregation
over large data volumes.
And to build a
platform upon which
both our users and our product
can grow for the future.
Now Cloud Logging is uniquely
positioned for log analytics.
Cloud Logging provides an
integrated logging solution,
both for services that
are running on top of GCP,
as well as logs that are
generated externally.
This includes log collection,
routing, storage, and analysis.
All the things you need
in a logging platform.
So in Cloud Logging, log
collection is really easy.
Logs for services
on Google Cloud
are automatically
collected, and it's
easy to collect other
infrastructure and application
logs if you need to.
Getting the right logs is easy.
It's a first critical step for
the logging analytics, as well.
The second thing
is the logs router.
It provides powerful
routing capabilities.
The built in routing routes
logs to Cloud Logging, other GCP
services like Cloud
Storage, and even
to external third party
tools with integration
through Pub/Sub.
Now for log analytics
the platform routes
logs to BigQuery.
The storage platform provides
scalable log management
capabilities.
These capabilities
provide controls
around what logs are stored,
where they're stored,
how long they're stored, and
who can access them to meet
your compliance requirements.
For logging analysis, this
manages the storage and access
in BigQuery.
Cloud Logging already provides
several tools to analyze
logs, each with
special purposes.
The Logs Explorer is a tool
optimized for troubleshooting
use cases with great
features like log streaming,
a log Resource Explorer, and
a histogram for visualization.
You have error
reporting, which helps
users react to critical
application errors
through automated error
grouping and notifications.
And through log based metrics
dashboards and alerting,
which all provide other
ways to understand and make
your logs actionable for
operational use cases.
Our new Log Analytics
feature expands this toolset
to include ad hoc log
analysis capabilities.
Taken together, Cloud Logging
provides a powerful platform
specifically designed
for working with logs.
So what is Log
Analytics exactly?
Log analytics extends
the capabilities
provided by Cloud Logging
in several important ways.
First, log analytics
automatically
stores logs in BigQuery with
a simple configuration setup.
With a checkbox,
enable Log Analytics
when you're creating
a log bucket,
you can use Cloud
Logging's pipeline
to make it easy to store
those logs, which you can then
analyze in Log Analytics.
Second, we're excited
for our new purpose built
log analytics UI, which provides
access to the logs using SQL.
SQL is a well known, widely
use domain specific language,
has powerful aggregation
capabilities,
and of course it's
widely used in BigQuery.
When you need to group by,
or sum, or find a ratio,
Log Analytics supports the
same standard SQL functions
provided by BigQuery.
Now the Log Analytics UI
provides an optimized results
experience designed
specifically for working
with unstructured log data.
And you'll see more of this
experience in the demo later.
Third, logs included in
Log Analytics are made
available directly in BigQuery.
If users need to join logs
with another data source,
they can run the same
query in Log Analytics
UI and the BigQuery UI and
join that data with data
already in BigQuery.
So by making this log data
available where users need it,
Log Analytics can help
remove data silos.
So how can you benefit from
these new capabilities?
Log Analytics can
help reduce the need
to send logs to so
many different systems
to address the
separate use cases.
I'll cover three common
use cases as examples.
First is for the DevOps team.
Resolving issues quickly is
critical to maintaining system
reliability, especially
with user facing services.
Log analytics helps here by
helping users more quickly find
patterns by correlating
IDs across services
so that you can reduce
outages more quickly.
Faster troubleshooting
can also help improve
the speed of
software development
by reducing time spent on
debugging and therefore
freeing up developer time.
The second is security.
Investigations are
a critical part
of understanding and
remediating security threats.
Log Analytics can help
here by finding logs
across large time ranges, which
often means large data volumes.
The third is IT operations.
Managing a fleet of
different services
is a core part of IT
operations, and it's
important to understand
the events and trends
across the whole fleet.
Log Analytics helps
here by identifying
patterns and the fleet
performance over time.
Now there are many
ways that Log Analytics
can help enable business
decisions, including analyzing
business data reported in logs.
And by unlocking
valuable insights,
Log Analytics brings
new value to your logs.
And now, since there's no better
way to show off a new feature,
let's see a demo.
In this demo, I'll show you
the new log analytics UI,
an example of
combining data stored
in Log Analytics with
other data in BigQuery.
I'll highlight the capabilities
offered by Log Analytics
to address two use cases.
One is the DevOps
troubleshooting use case,
and the other is a
security use case.
For the demo I've instances
of the online boutique,
which is an open source
microservices demo app.
It's deployed to two
GK clusters, which
are generating logs,
which are ingested
into Cloud Logging using the
out of the box configuration.
I've set up a logging
sink to capture the logs
and send them to Log Analytics
Enable bucket in Cloud Logging.
With a click of a
checkbox, logs are
available both in Log
Analytics and Cloud Logging
and in BigQuery.
First let's look at
the Log Analytics
UI, which is a new UI Cloud
Logging optimized for viewing
logging data.
In the Log Analytics UI,
use the same standard SQL
that is available in BigQuery.
SQL queries are used
to view the log data
and can range from
simple or complex.
There's a Query
Builder here where
you can enter your SQL
in a results viewer
to view the query results.
To start, let's take a look
at the completed Kubernetes
logs for the front end
service over the past hour.
Once the query is valid
I can run the query.
Now the Log
Analytics UI provides
two specific optimizations that
have been added to BigQuery
and used by Log Analytics.
The first is that
JSON value function,
which allows you to
extract JSON data
and compare it to strings, which
is really useful for queries
like this or when you
want to look at the string
results of data stored in JSON.
And the second optimisation
is the JSON dot notation.
Notice that the JSON
payload dot message field
is actually using
the dot notation
to refer to a field inside
the JSON structure of a JSON
payload.
Both of these make it easier
to work with JSON data.
The results are displayed
using a view optimized
for working with log data.
You can see that the
JSON payload is actually
stored as JSON data, which
means that any JSON structured
data can be stored in there
without having to know
or specify the schema up front.
Log Analytics UI, the
JSON data, is actually
displayed using JSON
[INAUDIBLE] format
to make it even easier to use.
Now by looking at
some of these logs,
I notice that there is a
value inside these logs, which
is the response
took milliseconds,
which is the time the
request took to complete.
So one of the
things we can do is
look at the min, max,
and average values
of that over time.
These kind of queries can be
very useful in troubleshooting.
So let's take a look at
what this would look like.
There we go.
OK.
So what we're doing here is
we're extracting this field,
and we're casting it as an
integer so we can do the sum.
We're also taking the hour.
And then what we're
doing is we're
grouping, looking at the
minimum, the maximum,
and the average value.
But what we notice by
looking at the results here
is that around hour
14, both the maximum
as well as the average time
increased substantially.
So this gives me great insight
during troubleshooting,
and it can help me
more quickly identify
the signals, which can help me
resolve issues more quickly.
Well, Log Analytics
provides the flexibility
to look at individual
logs, as you see,
and run complex
aggregations, s which
can help surface critical
insights for the DevOps team
when troubleshooting an issue.
Now let's take a look at
the security use case.
Again, staying with
the same scenario,
the app deployed to GKE.
This time let's look
at the security related
logs for application
and infrastructure.
We can do that by using
a query like this.
The main difference
here is that we're
looking at the proto
payload field here
and we're looking
for audit logs.
So why don't we run the query.
Here's what the audit logs
look like in Log Analytics.
You can see that they are the
record type within BigQuery,
and you can see that there's a
detailed structure of the audit
log within the
proto payload field.
There's a lot of
information that's
stored within an audit log,
and it's actually displayed
in the UI using the
JSON [INAUDIBLE] format
to make it easier to work with.
All of the fields that are
actually stored as a record
type are also displayed
using the JSON data type
to make it easier to work with.
Again, what's more interesting
is to look at the aggregations.
So let's take a
look at the audit
logs grouped by the
principal and the IP address
fields, which are
the users as well
as the IP address from which
those actions originated.
Great.
So now we can see both email
address and the IP address
and the number of calls that
have originated from both.
Now for security use
cases, sometimes it's
useful to search for a value
in a log without knowing which
specific field.
The newly added search
function in BigQuery
allows you to do just that.
The function searches across an
entire table or set of columns
to find a value.
To demonstrate, let's pick an IP
address and find all the audit
logs associated with the IP
across any field in the table.
And we can do that by
using the search function,
specifying the table, as well
as the IP address defined.
So by using the
search function I've
been able to find all of the
records that are associated
or include this
particular IP address.
This is extraordinarily useful
for unstructured data that is
stored in JSON in other fields.
For example, it's not limited
to IP address or just for audit
logs.
It can be used generally
across any of the fields
within BigQuery.
Now one of the powerful
features of Log Analytics
is it also provides you
with access to the same log
data in BigQuery.
While Log Analytics provides
an optimized UI and one
that evolves to add
more optimizations,
having access to
log data in BigQuery
means that you can
join the log data
with other data and BigQuery.
By clicking the Run in
BigQuery link in Log Analytics,
the same query is
loaded in BigQuery.
And running that will
return the same results
with the standard
BigQuery formatting.
You'll notice it's
the same data.
However, the results
appear differently
for the proto
[INAUDIBLE] format.
Now in BigQuery, we can
combine that IP address data
that we looked up in
the previous example
with other data.
As an example, I'll combine the
IP address with a public data
set and use the
functions in BigQuery
to produce a list
of all the countries
and the number of logs for each.
We can do that with this query.
Here we have the
Select statement,
which will look at all of the
audit logs over the past 30
days and select the IP addresses
from them as well as the count.
And here we'll join that
data with a public data set,
as well as use the
BigQuery IP functions
to be able to get the
country associated
with each of those IPs.
So by combining
the audit log data
with the geolocation
public data set,
I've been able to gain insight
into the requests coming
from different countries.
Most of the requests have
come from the United States.
I do see that other requests
have originated from places
outside the United States.
This combination can
provide powerful insights.
So to recap, Log Analytics
and Cloud Logging
provides a powerful way
to analyze your logs
based on the power of BigQuery.
The Log Analytics UI
provides an optimized way
to view and work with log
data, and the log data
stored in Log Analytics is made
available directly in BigQuery
for joining with other data.
While we're excited
about Log Analytics,
we're already hard at work
making it both easier to use
and more powerful.
To make it easier to
use, we're working
on adding a new visualization
result type via charts,
so that users can more easily
understand their query results.
We're also working to simplify
the user query experience.
We know that not everybody
is a SQL expert, which
is why we're working
to make it easier
to gain the benefits
of Logging Analytics
without becoming a SQL expert.
We're also working to enable
Log Analytics by default.
This will make it
easier for any users
to access the advanced
logging capabilities.
Now to make Log Analytics
an even more powerful tool,
we're working on
logging insights.
Logging insights can surface
data that you would otherwise
have to search to find.
By analyzing data
proactively, Logging Analytics
can help uncover
powerful insights,
such as proactive
recommendations.
We're also working
to expand the scope
to include other
operational data.
By combining logs data with
other operational data,
such as trace data, you
can gain even more context
for a more rich analysis.
We're really excited about
launching the Log Analytics
feature today, and we're
excited to see the powerful ways
that you'll use these
new capabilities.
So on behalf of the whole Cloud
Logging and BigQuery teams,
thank you for watching.
To learn more about
Logging Analytics
and Cloud Logging
please visit our Docs
and sign up for the
preview to get started.